citizens of the reject Nation we just got out
of watching killers of the flower moon on IMAX I
want to thank IMAX for inviting us I want to thank
Gabriella especially for inviting us because she
is letting us shoot here right now when everything
is cleared out and we want to make this short Port
patience she is being so kind to let us shoot this
like obnoxious teenagers wanting to make a little
Vlog video for you guys so with that in mind IMAX
is the best thing in the world the second we were
invited was one that we said yes to right away
reason why Martin scorsi especially on my end
between the two of us is my all-time favorite
director so the idea of seeing one of his movies
on my favorite screen and I'm not just saying
that it is my favorite screen yeah I have to see
killers of the flower Moon so undoubtedly a very
bias I'm going to be like yeah it's the best way
to watch this movie IM Max it all the way but with
that in mind like I said we got to keep it short
we didn't know anything about this movie before
watching it we never did a trailer reaction action
for it all I knew was scorsi dairo DiCaprio the
two greatest leading actors my favorite director
has done multiple films with and now he's going
to be directing them in the same movie have to
go see it and apparently this is a based on a
true story one of the greatest things I can say
about it is it it feels that way it feels true
like the entire time out of a three and a half
hour experience it just Rings authentic it never
ever Del into a Hollywood even when you think it's
going to go like a Hollywood Trope it never goes
to the Hollywood Trope you think it's going to go
to this is not a Christopher Nolan period piece no
no there's nothing that feels Fantastical about it
you know no you're it very much feels like a fly
on the wall it has almost like a documentary type
quality if you've ever seen like a Ken Burns you
know American history it has that kind of Aura
and to the point of how authentic it feels um
I got to tell you guys what this movie is about
something again we did not know about which felt
like a big educational experience I must say makes
you want to read so in the 1920s uh in Oklahoma
the O they discovered oil which brought them
a lot of wealth and then with having wealth you
know sometimes white people step in and they go
hey let me actually let me explain please please
take it away what did you guys do well you know
we saw the opportunity and we're like how can
we iate ourselves to what is clearly something
we are owed by just being here at home clearly
how do you plant your destiny baby plant your
seed and then manage to take away the fortune and
maybe that involves murdering some people so that
way you can speed up the process of inheritance
I don't know nothing Greg I don't know nothing
it explores that main topic a largely forgotten
part of History it also was I I believe one of
the earliest cases if not the first major case of
the FBI like the way they talk about it at least
in this movie yeah certainly it feels like it's a
fresh occurrence you there's already all this you
know Federal suspicion anyway so now to have you
know investigators coming out from there yeah it
is a cold film it is a taut film it is one that
definitely requires um a lot of patience I will
say that like the first hour to an hour and a half
like it it does have it's like it is a slow movie
the last half of this movie is where you really
start to get a lot more of like that payoff for
your patience where a lot of the intensity does
start to really unfold because a lot of it's so
like it's it's consistently interesting but then
that's when it starts getting like oh wow there
the corruption is getting really intense at this
point but let's talk about the performances really
quick now obviously DiCaprio the star of this
movie uh he plays a guy named Ernest who meets
up with his uncle played by Bob dairo Bobby D
Bobby D who is the villain of this movie he he's
someone who likes to you know pose as righteous
and a man for the people and I'm I'm not one of
these other white people I'm one of the ones who's
good good with good ones I speak your language I
know your customs and I'm here for you he knows
how to take advantage of everyone and it's one
of Dao's best performances uh in years probably
since the Irish and him and DiCaprio do play off
each other really well it's a really twisted
type of because it's his uncle but it's more
of a father Sun Dynamic yeah absolutely and it's
something that grows and Es and flows throughout
so it's something that's going to really give you
the weight of that Clash that you want between
these two heavyweights and then you got Leonardo
Caprio playing um I think his third Southern drunk
bumbling idiot you're a [__] miserable drunk yes
yes this time the biggest idiot ever honestly it's
a it's a really great performance it's very
believable like he just he's like a rotting
pumpkin in this movie you know he really is yeah
and he's such a sad sack Mushmouth kind of guy
and if he had any kind of like you you spend the
movie wishing he would grow a spine but that's
part of what's interesting about the character
in general is how he is completely manipulated
and pushed around by every circumstance around
him except for one you know which is uh the the
third you know kind of biggest performance of
the movie I would say which is Lily Gladstone
which everyone's highlighting certainly for good
reason yeah Lily Gladstone plays DiCaprio's wife
she is one the one of the wealthy OS people who
uh you know DiCaprio marries in this movie it's
tough to get into it without really spoiling
anything like that but dairo wants DiCaprio
to marry her for to inherit the wealth and the
thing is DiCaprio part of the complexity with this
character that makes him actually interesting is
no he actually loves his wife truly yeah but her
performance wow I cannot imagine the torture she
went through truly it is a very it's a restrained
performance very when I heard people praising her
yeah that's when I heard people praising her work
I thought it was going to be something where
oh she's going to get a bunch of big scenes of
of just monologues of tears and stuff but it's
the actually the opposite of that while there's
anguish in a lot of scenes it it's a surprisingly
restrained but really she does command the screen
whenever she's there you know she really does
she has a great presence and so much of the
painful heart of the movie is told through
her eyes basically very very strong there's
a great like cast all around what I loved about
the casting in in general is I didn't recognize
90% of them I feel like indigenous people who were
cast the Native American people who were cast they
they felt like they just real people that they
cast and I would even say the same thing for the
white people who were casting this movie this is
full of of great casting acoss feel authentic and
yeah a bunch of character actors who look like
they were just plucked out of the time yeah yeah
like you eventually get some of your more famous
people who do show up but it's often so late into
the movie it has that quality of the movie being
so imbued by its time and place and the casting
like this is a movie that's very composed and
everything from the production designs to the
cast that fills those sets and those spaces it
all really feels again researched and lived in
that's one of the best things I could say about
it is you could tell just like the analytical
details about this capturing this period piece to
the point where you do feel like you're kind of
plucked in time in one of the harshest ways you
can imagine because there's nothing like flowery
about the way its emotionality is expressed like
a lot of times never melodramatic the camera just
lingers on scenes you know a lot of times like
oh man we haven't cut away from this one guy
just talking for a very long time there's a lot
of great seamwork a lot of Great Performances
very performance Reliant and I think the one thing
with the experience of it is the movie did kind of
weirdly out of three and a half hours kind of
keep me at a distance it does yeah because it
is so cold that I never really got emotionally
like I appreciate everything the movie's doing
and I love what the the top I don't love what
it it's about but I I love that the movies do
in this story you know yeah however I never quite
got emotionally hooked into someone's Journey you
know to the point where I'm on the journey with
them kind of the thing you'd want out of a 3 and
a half hour film yeah and nor is it like a good
Fellas for example which is which is kind of funny
to me because there were ear marks of this that
are like oh even though it's completely different
from the things SC says he's become famous for a
lot of it's actually a little bit of a mob movie
no it is certainly or like a crime family crime
family yeah just just Circ of the old west but
yeah a lot of that like yeah crime organization
made man stuff you know yeah yeah it's the way
how he did Irishman which was a mob movie that
felt very meditative this is kind of like that
with a more of a periop slant and kind of a dark
dramatic Western flare to it yeah yeah that neow
Western sort of Noir kind of thing yeah as it has
that like percolating drum bass beat throughout
yeah I really like the music in this I thought it
was nicely kind of a blend of things that would
come after but things that are also very rooted
in Native music yes it shines a great light on
the horrible atrocities that went down and it
is an important story to tell you can feel how
important this story is you can feel the fervor
behind the film making and the writing behind it
as well and while the dialogue does feel very
true at the same time I could definitely feel
the movie's runtime and while I think the last
half is way more engaging than the first half I
still was never quite as emotionally pulled in
in a way that was beyond an observation piece
yeah it's there's certain Fascination to be had
and and certainly things to ruminate on when
you're watching so many of the purveyors of these
atrocities both through greed and mination and
also through dim wittedness and and the kind of
painful mess that all of that represents and the
thing for me was I really really liked so much of
the work that was on display throughout the movie
beautifully shot lots of great compositions lots
of great acting like you said the Molly character
Lily Gladstone's character is the closest the
movie brings you to having like an emotionally
sympathetic eyeline but even with her it kind
of keeps you at an arms length so yeah I wish
it was a little bit more from her perspective I
do too yeah cuz I I I feel like after a while I
can imagine certain viewers sort of feeling like
maybe we are dipping into tragedy suffering porn
a little bit you the kind of thing ciles look
sure sitting for three and a half hours I you
know while it is an important story it's also you
know there are arguments to be had about how not
to just just make it a slog through trauma Town
basically not to say that those things aren't
legitimate but yeah there is a coldness that I
could see certain people maybe not being able to
latch on to I'm still really glad that I watched
it because I I truly felt like it's rare I watch
a movie where I'm really I really feel like
I learned something from this movie yeah and
I want to unpack it and I want to like I want to
learn more I want to read about this it's one of
those movies clearly so much about its message
I actually want to learn more about the message
yeah totally that's a good that's a good way to
describe it I think and that's not just me being
kind and it was the feeling that I had like I
had to look it up after cuz I'm like man was
this DiCaprio guy just such a dumbass in real
life after it does sort of remind it reminded
me of like of the master in that kind of way
where you have this protagonist who you're like
is this guy going on an arc or a journey or is he
just kind of bumbling his way and and just being
direct is he just a true Pawn in this horrible
horrible game that you know yeah has so many
different touchstones in American history from a
technical film making standpoint I would give it
like a like a nine out of 10 from just a movie
goinging experience I would probably honestly
just give it like a seven out of 10 yeah we're
probably in in agreement like there's so much
to appreciate but if you're really going to be
swept up in the movie that's kind of that'll vary
yeah that definitely varies I heard some people
walking out who really loved it and I heard some
others who were like eh and and I'm more like
no I got like two feelings about it and those
are my two feelings guys leave your thoughts down
below of what your favorite scorsi film is thank
you to IMX again again we got to get out of here
uh pull us out with you guys for listening to us
talk